nous allons parler à présent d'une
rencontre de jeunes entrepreneurs des
yvelines et c'est le confinement qu'il
l'a rendu possible nous sommes avec
camille lefeuvre présidente et
fondatrice de péage fragrance bonjour
vous êtes au mesnil-le-roi et nous
sommes aussi avec julie et kevin antoine
du studio jules bonjour à vous de à vous
deux pardon vous êtes à maisons laffitte
on va parler de votre rencontre
virtuelle de votre collaboration va tout
d'abord présenté aussi pour les
téléspectateurs vos activités
respectives
camille lefeuvre votre entreprise
propose des parfums de luxe des produits
parfumés réalisé avec un cahier des
charges très restrictif
c'est une marque qui se veut sans aucun
produit toxique c'est bien ça déjà pour
vous présenter
exactement nous on a créé un amas on a
créé la chimie qui une écologie qui sont
divinement et on a fallu parfois grands
parents donc on a des parfums ondes et
suivent des bougies des vêtements
parfums des gels douches ddo est décrié
derrière moi on a obtenu fammac mépris
sur notre engagement pour la santé ou
l'environnement
donc on va effectivement interdit plus
anciens gagnants contre lui c'est en
plus des réglementations en vigueur
avant de confinement comment se porte
votre activité justement plutôt bien ça
a été plus compliqué avec le début du go
finement et cette crise
oui c'est évident nous on est au tout
début france a maintenu plein de prix
pour notre innovation inédite en france
ensuite quand aussi en angleterre sur le
confinement à cette crise énorme sur nos
petites stars il ya les magasins sont
fermés
comment penser c'est effectivement la
réalité déjà entre les mains d'antoine
votre studio est donc basé photo studio
de photographie à maisons-laffitte ou
vous adresser aux familles aux
professionnels aussi aujourd'hui votre
activité est totalement à l'arrêt oui
clairement clairement
forcément avec le confinement plus
personne ne peut sortir donc tout ce qui
est chouette un petit peu particulier
basse est à l'arrêt et les grosses
marques avec lesquelles on bosse
notamment bosse avec l' agence de
mannequins élite on bosse avec beaucoup
de marques de prêt-à-porter bien
évidemment pas tout ce qui t as les
campagnes photos sont pour le moment
reporter en espérant que ce soit pas
annulée donc c'est vrai que bon là du
temps en habitants comme ça c'est pour
ça qu'avec a mis bas on lui a suggéré
c'est vrai qu'on s'est posé la question
avec julien on s'est dit tiens qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour aider les gens
se rendent ce temps de crise on a
réfléchi on s'est dit ce qu on sait
coudre
non non on est bête ça bah non
donc on s'est dit voilà julie et
mannequin moi je suis photographe et on
s'est dit tiens si on pouvait aider les
créateurs à faire face un petit peu en
composant un petit peu de contenu en
leur faisant des photos avec avec julie
avec est avec moi et on a même mis les
enfants à contribution je n'aime pas ça
et peut-être un petit peu je sais pas
moi donner un petit coup de main ces
entrepreneurs son arrêt petit culte et
doux c'est comme ça qu'est venu en fait
finalement pas notre but est de
travailler et camille oui on avait
proposé gratuitement vos services pour
créer en quelques jours et pendant le
confinement c'est une publicité
on va voir la fiche d'ailleurs à
l'antenne pendant qu'on parlait comme
ans comment s'est passé le travail un
petit peu pour arriver à cette création
de part et d'autre comment vous avez
échangé et ben en fait on a en en a on a
communiqué avec camille on voit là où il
a dit voilà écoute on lui a soumis le
projet on lui a expliqué un petit peu se
doit ce qu'on pouvait faire ce dont elle
avait besoin
donc elle nous a fait parvenir leur
envoyer des produits il va envoyer un
parfum d'envoyer voilà toutes les
sirènes vont envoyer plusieurs petits
produits laon celui bâtir le parfum
c'est super
julie bas qu'à l'habitude de travailler
beaucoup on peut semer tic qui fait la
une en rêvant de pub ce soit télé ou
alors des affiches pour voilà pour pas
qu'on prend beaucoup de place et y
penser tiens le parfum ce serait
vraiment quelque chose vous pourrez tous
éclaté en tant que photographe qui
pourrait servir à camille pour ça comme
donc on a mis un shoot en place assez
rapidement
voilà à la météo ça et on peut donc là
c'est parti comme ça et on a mis aussi
d'ailleurs
après le chute à contribution nos
internautes
non
notre réseau donc retoucheur graphistes
etc pour pouvoir monter une affiche
vraiment trop et tout ça gratuitement
évidemment m lefevbre justement c'est
cette initiative
ça permet de soutenir aussi votre
activité ça permet une solidarité entre
entrepreneurs tout à fait donc ses
initiatives forcément chaud au coeur
c'est une très belle initiative une très
belle en paix dans trois ans tout
entrepreneur donc ces initiatives liste
moi j'ai été très touchée il ya eu plus
de 1500 personnes qui ont participé de
nos réseaux sur la fiche et la fiche à
la voix magnifique et du coup moi j'ai
relayé également sur des réseaux sociaux
linkedin facebook il ya eu trente mille
pu en quelques heures on peut mini fiat
yves a été fait une cité mois les rendre
aussi un peu de ce qu'on venait et donc
j'ai besson c'est que tout achat de
produits ce faux mails sur le site
internet est à 50 euros qui sont
reversés au fonds a fait acheter le
fonds d'urgence et l'esprit des hôpitaux
de paris paris pour les médecins et on
la recherche
c'est une petite contribution
un homme c'est dans ces moments un
prêtre d'une solidarité de part et
d'autre qui s'est organisée joli et
kevin antoine vous continuez ce genre
d'initiative avec d'autres entreprises
d'autres shooting photo je dis qu'on n'a
pas encore entendu il sera mis à
contribution aussi on a dit que ce soir
je veux
un mariage on a plein plein de marques
de prêt-à-porter
sinon bonne dizaine facile peu de jeunes
entreprises créateurs et ça va permettre
des collaborations futures peut-être on
imagine aussi ça permet d'étoffer le
carnet d'adressés parce que ces
entreprises
l'un comme l'autre va bien falloir les
faire vivre aussi après au moment du
décompte final
c'est vrai qu'on sait c'est pas
forcément le but on sait pas où on va on
va shooter les marques
on va après bosser bosser avec lui en
fait on a on a lancé le vraiment les
shootings gratuit pour un pour aider les
entrepreneurs
après on verra évidemment c'est sûr si
on travaille bien et que bas les
entreprises ont besoin pour le futur de
photos dès qu'ils font appel à nous mais
c'est vrai que s'ils font pas la peine
qu'on sait pas c'est pas le but on est
vraiment là dans une optique d'entre
aide parce que ben voilà c'est un peu la
situation actuelle qui nécessite de
qu'on soit tous les uns avec les autres
pour pouvoir tous basm elle met à
contribution mais pourquoi faire face à
cette crise
merci à tous les trois jours donne le
nom de l'entreprise elle s'affiche aussi
les sites internet le studio jules que
donc et ph fragrance
merci à tous les trois et bravo pour ces
initiatives merci à vous 6